hi my name is Jason Tomlinson I'm an
engineering manager at hands on mobile
i'm here today to talk to you about an
Android application I've written which
uses the accelerometer feature of the
platform the game is called amazed the
whole idea of the game is to navigate a
marvel through the maze by tilting the
device in various directions whatever
direction until the device the mob will
follow the same path you have to try and
navigate the marble to the light blue
area which then take you to the next
level as you progress through the ten
levels of the game each level gets
progressively harder until you get to
level 10 which is almost impossible so
that's the game you can find an open
source on the apps for Android project
why does only a simple technical demo
ability to play around with the
accelerometer feature of the Android
platform I was brought from the fact i
was working on guitar hero world tour
which we bring to the android platform
fully leveraging all the specific
features including multiplayer battle
mode so you and your friends can play
against each other in real time